[Música]
rusia y ucrania acordaron un corredor
humanitario pero continúan los
bombardeos fue atacada la aldea de jaime
a 5 km del segundo aeropuerto de kiev y
en la norteña chernigov fue recuperar un
33 cuerpos y otras el impacto de misiles
analizamos en esta emisión
más y más ucranianos se llegan a la
unión europea que por primera vez en 20
años ordenó un estatus de protección
especial para los refugiados más de un
millón de urania nos hoy ya cruzaron las
fronteras
y en noticias de francia a un día de que
venciera el plazo del presidente de
manuel macrón anunció oficialmente su
candidatura a la reelección y lo hizo a
través de una carta a los ciudadanos las
encuestas lo favorecen en la intención
de voto tenemos reportes desde parís
un cordial saludo mi nombre es ángela
gómez y aquí comienzan las noticias de
la noche en francés 24
terminó la segunda ronda de diálogo
entre kiev y moscú un encuentro que dio
los primeros frutos se crearán
corredores humanitarios para evacuar a
los civiles de las zonas de
confrontación y se habló de la
posibilidad de un alto el fuego temporal
en esos puntos mientras esas decisiones
se hacen efectivas siguen los bombardeos
rusos la población de jaime ubicada a
unos cinco kilómetros del segundo
aeropuerto de kiev evalúa los daños tras
una ofensiva por aire que dejó al menos
un fallecido y un herido y al menos 33
cuerpos fueron recuperados de tras el
embate de las fuerzas rusas en la ciudad
desértico y es que con su principal
fuerza de asalto detenida durante días
en una carretera al norte de kiev rusia
ha cambiado de táctica intensificando
los bombardeos de las ciudades
precisamente vamos al análisis de la
estrategia rusa en la invasión a ucrania
nos acompaña el doctor richard downie
coronel retirado del ejército de eeuu y
analista militar gracias doctor y las
fuerzas rusas atacaron ucrania
prácticamente desde todos los puntos
cardinales entraron por belarús por el
donbass y también por los puertos del
sur en qué consiste el asedio usted cree
que su avance va de acuerdo a lo
planeado como dijo putin
pues gracias ángela es un placer estar
consigo pues no exactamente
el plan de putin claramente los cursos
están teniendo éxito en el sur del país
tomando este ciudad de puerto que son
porque ellos tienen tienen superioridad
naval en el mar blau negro
pero los los ataques hacia cif y karki
kharkiv han sido mal bastante lento de
acuerdo con el paso que los rusos le
buscan y les gustarían haber obtenido
pero a lo que pasó ahora es realmente
grave en términos de que están atacando
como usted acaba de mencionar
a las ciudades de química aquí nosotros
con blancos como xavi les civiles e
infraestructura dentro de las ciudades
con el fin de intimidar a el pueblo
civil para que se fueran mire sin
embargo y como usted nos está diciendo
parece que está tomando más tiempo de lo
planeado de esta toma usted cree que
esto se debe al apoyo militar
internacional
no yo creo que de lo que parece fue por
las expectativas de que rusia tenía es
que ellos pensaron que iban a tener
alguna entrada en el país e iban a ir
directamente al active y ver a los que
no iban a tener resistencia por las
fuerzas militares de ucrania no yo creo
que no esperaban tanta resistencia por
parte de la del lado del pueblo civil
entonces hay esos pensamientos de cuidar
del paso que iba a tener no fue correcto
por eso estamos viendo estos esos
problemas logísticas que se están
teniendo
allá especialmente el área norte de
quito
y sin embargo nos quedamos con la
pregunta que será para otra ocasión de
como la artillería ucraniana va a
resistir al segundo ejército más
poderoso del mundo gracias a usted por
estar con nosotros y continuamos con más
noticias en una decisión sin precedentes
la unión europea aprobó por primera vez
otorgar el estatus de protección
especial para los refugiados de la
invasión rusa que según acnur son más de
un millón de personas los ucranianos
podrán moverse libremente por cualquier
estado de la unión europea durante un
año y podrán prorrogar este permiso
especial por seis meses
dos veces entretanto suramérica abre
también sus puertas brasil anunció que
les concederá un pasaporte humanitario y
el presidente de argentina alberto
fernández dijo que su gobierno estudia
ofrecer refugio a los ucranianos y es
que el país australia ya acoge a la
diáspora ucraniana más grande de américa
latina y la séptima del mundo
natalio coso en nuestro corresponsal en
buenos aires- él conversó con algunos de
ellos
pirineo baluk y su esposa susana ruiz
siguen atentos las noticias de la guerra
en ucrania irineo no puede evitar el
recuerdo de su propia salida de ese país
sobre el final de la segunda guerra
material a que está el tactics muestra
orgulloso este tapiz que su abuela les
hizo poner a su familia en el carro para
viajar más cómodos y que aún conserva
justamente ahora cuando yo lo veo este y
me pone el lugar y se me mire se me se
me humedecen los ojos porque me pongo en
el lugar de ellos que ellos también
estaban yo tenía cinco años y ahora veo
también están a otros jóvenes que
también padecen lo que yo ya padecía y
por suerte lo pude superar y deseo de
que ellos también superen
para manifestar su rechazo a la guerra a
la comunidad ucraniana en argentina ya
realizó varias marchas en buenos aires
como esta frente a la embajada rusa en
la que estuvo irineo o esta otra en la
plaza de mayo en la que había algunas
ucranianos recientemente llegados al
país angustiados por lo que ocurre en su
tierra si antes estaba viendo en buenos
aires ahora estoy viendo en internet
estoy viviendo en noticias en chats con
mi familia
cada mañana y cada noche es como estáis
estáis bien estáis bien y cuando llevan
a horas sin contestar eso te asusta
mientras tanto irineo y susana se reúnen
con sus hijos en su casa para compartir
novedades de sus parientes en ucrania
irineo y susana que es hija de
inmigrantes ucranianos son católicos de
rito oriental de la iglesia bizantina yo
como católico
apoyo la oración que para mí
fuerza de la oración es importante por
eso en el fondo espero que
evite un milagro vote por él en la
comunidad ucraniana argentina cada uno a
su manera irineo y susana rezando piden
por el final de la guerra en la que está
sumida en su tierra ancestral casas
hasta islas de la luz la xiv y en otras
noticias el presidente de francés
emmanuel mccrone formalizó su
candidatura a las elecciones
presidenciales de abril en una carta que
publicaron varios medios regionales
aunque se estimaba que makro no iba a
aspirar a su reelección de todavía no lo
había confirmado y lo hizo un día antes
de que se venciera el plazo desde parís
nuestra periodista natalia ruiz nos
amplió
para nadie era un secreto que emanuel a
maco buscará ser reelegido como
presidente de la república se esperaba
era el día del anuncio y finalmente fue
este jueves en la noche a través de una
carta que fue publicada en varios
diarios regionales de todo el país una
carta extensa dirigida a los franceses
en donde el presidente hace por una
parte un balance de lo que han sido
estos cinco años de gobierno donde ella
subraya logros como la disminución de
los impuestos mayor inversión en la
salud también en la seguridad y
disminución de la tasa de desempleo la
más baja de los últimos 15 años pero
maicon también es consciente de que han
sido cinco años de muchísimas crisis en
especial estos dos últimos años de
pandemia y en medio de todo esto pues él
pide a los franceses que le vuelvan a
dar a su confianza para los próximos
cinco años en esta carta del presidente
no da a conocer cuál va a ser su
programa de gobierno cuáles serían las
grandes líneas pero da algunas luces por
una parte un proyecto muy centrado en la
economía en la independencia económica
del país sobre todo energética y por
otra parte un lugar muy importante para
la educación la escuela que debe ser un
lugar de oportunidades para y donde los
maestros deben ser respetados y mejor
remunerados con termina esta carta
diciendo que esta campaña no va a tener
la forma no va a tomar la forma que él
esperaba en medio de este contexto
internacional en el que se está viviendo
con este conflicto entre ucrania y rusia
así que eso es lo que resta por saber
cómo va a hacer esta campaña cómo van a
hacer los debates con los demás
candidatos y sobre todo cuándo será su
primer mitin de campaña porque
justamente el primero el que se tenía
previsto para este sábado fue cancelado
en medio de la situación que se está
viviendo aquí hasta aquí el informativo
pero ya volvemos con más y sigue en
directo nuestro cubrimiento
internacional de la invasión rusa a
ucrania siga con nosotros
[Música]